The state of Iowa has a little more than three million people. One million come to the State Fair. I'm strolling past the swine barn, and the kids' talent show stage, and the lemonade shake up stands, and the many, many corn dog stands, and the Central Iowa Railroad Club Exhibit building, and the chainsaw art, and the live snakes, and the vast, slowly moving rivers of people.
爱荷华州拥有三百多万人口。其中一百万人会来到州博览会。我漫步经过养猪场、儿童才艺表演舞台、柠檬水摊位、许许多多玉米热狗摊、中爱荷华铁路俱乐部展览馆、电锯艺术展、活蛇展示区，以及那广阔且缓慢流动的人潮。
Every one of those million is here on their own personal quest for what they want out of the fair. Stuff they want to do, stuff they want to see, everybody has their own mission. Declan and Killian, for instance, seven and nine years old, brothers from a suburb of Des Moines. They want to see the giant bull. Killian, the big brother, talked to my co-worker, Diane Wu.
那一百万人中的每一个人来到这里，都是为了追求他们想从博览会中获得的东西。每个人都有自己想做的事、想看的东西，都有各自的任务。比如七岁和九岁的兄弟德克兰和基利安，来自得梅因郊区。他们想看巨型公牛。哥哥基利安和我同事戴安·吴聊了聊。
Why are you so excited to see the bull?
你为什么这么兴奋想看公牛？
It's one of my favorite animals.
它是我最喜欢的动物之一。
How come?
为什么？
They can see red, and red is my favorite color.
它们能看到红色，而红色是我最喜欢的颜色。
What? You said it was black every day.
什么？你每天都说那是黑色。
His little brother Declan with a fact check about Killian's favorite color being black. Another fact check-- bulls can't actually see red. The boys wander around the outside of the cattle barn, looking for the right entrance.
弟弟德克兰对他哥哥基利安最喜欢的颜色是黑色的说法进行了事实核查。另一个事实核查——公牛其实看不到红色。男孩们在牛棚外徘徊，寻找正确的入口。
Super sized bull.
超大公牛。
Oh, I wonder if--
哦，我在想——
That way.
那边。
Yep.
没错。
The bull's name is Teddy Bear, and it weighs 3,060 pounds. Signs duct taped onto the pen say, do not touch the bull, which is, like, yeah.
这头公牛名叫泰迪熊，重达3060磅。围栏上用胶带贴着标语，写着“请勿触摸公牛”，确实如此。
What do you think?
你觉得怎么样？
That's cool. And big. I thought it would be smaller.
太酷了。而且很大。我以为它会小一点。
You thought it would be smaller.
你以为它会小一点。
A little bit.
稍微一点点。
When you see a giant animal, if you're a kid or an adult, what is there to say other than, yeah, OK. That's about right. Elsewhere--
当你看到一个庞然大物时，无论是孩子还是成年人，除了“好吧，确实如此”，还能说什么呢？在别处——
[GUNSHOTS]
[枪声]
Cowboy-mounted shooting is one of the fastest growing equestrian sports in the country. It's a timed event where we use two 45 single-action long Colt pistols.
骑马牛仔射击是该国发展最快的马术运动之一。这是一项计时赛事，我们使用两把45口径单动柯尔特长枪。
In the cowboy-mounted shooting competition, each competitor is on horseback. And they ride a course, shooting burning embers from their guns. They try to pop five balloons with one pistol. Then they change guns, shoot five more balloons with the other pistol, then gallop to the finish line, all without stopping.
在骑马牛仔射击比赛中，每位选手都要骑在马上。他们穿过赛道，从枪中射出燃烧的火花。他们尝试用一把手枪击落五个气球。然后换枪，用另一把手枪再击落五个气球，接着全速奔向终点线，全程中途不停。
Some of these runs we're going to be doing today are going to be nine seconds, because that's less than a second per shot with a gun change. It's a lot happening all at once.
今天我们要进行的一些比赛时间可能会在九秒左右，因为这意味着更换枪支后，每发子弹的射击时间不到一秒。所有动作都要在瞬间完成。
Adam Ross is actually ranked sixth in the world at this sport, but somehow, he has never won first place here in his home state of Iowa. That's his mission for this year's fair, he told my co-worker, Ike Sriskandarajah.
亚当·罗斯在这项运动中的世界排名其实是第六，但不知何故，他从未在自己的家乡爱荷华州赢得过第一名。他告诉我的同事艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾，这就是他今年博览会的目标。
I'm naturally competitive. When everybody else puts their horses away in the winter, me and my wife take our horses to the barn and we ride all winter long. We try to outwork every one of our competitors.
我生来好胜。当其他人在冬天把马匹安置好时，我和我妻子会把马带到马厩，整个冬天都在练习。我们努力工作，超越每一位竞争对手。
And when you survey this room of competitive riders in your level, who's the one you're most keeping an eye on?
当你审视这个房间里和你水平相当的竞技骑手时，你最关注的是谁？
I look right in the mirror at myself. I know that I'm the fastest one here. I have the horse that's the most proven here this year. So as long as I don't beat myself when I go out there and run my match, I know that there's nobody that will compete with me.
我看着镜子里的自己。我知道我是这里最快的一个。我今年有这里表现最稳健的马。所以只要我在参加比赛时不出错，我知道没有人能与我竞争。
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
[CHOIR MUSIC]
[唱诗班音乐]
(SINGING) God will be with you until we meet again
（歌唱）上帝会与你同在，直到我们再次相遇
He blows better floating o'er you
他在你上方飘荡得更好
A slightly slower pace over at the replica of Iowa's first church. The original was built in 1834. It's a cozy log cabin, where the goal is to reflect on God's goodness right in the middle of a gigantic, noisy carnival. They hold services twice a day during the fair, where Iowans are not officially permitted to pray, but they are, the guy leading the service says, allowed have to sing prayers.
在爱荷华州第一座教堂的复制品那边节奏稍慢。最初的教堂建于1834年。那是一个舒适的圆木小屋，目标是在这个巨大嘈杂的嘉年华中心，反思上帝的仁慈。博览会期间，他们每天举行两次礼拜，据主持礼拜的人说，爱荷华州人虽然没有被正式允许祈祷，但被“允许”吟唱祷文。
[VOCALIZING]
[发声练习]
Thank you.
谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
High above nearly everything at this fair, looking down on everyone, stands Byaunda, age 11, on the giant slide for her very first time. It is a massive metal slide that you fly down on a felt mat. And she has a simple goal of her own.
在博览会几乎所有事物的高处，俯瞰着每个人，11岁的Byaunda第一次站在了巨型滑梯上。这是一个巨大的金属滑梯，你坐着毛毡垫子飞驰而下。她有一个自己的简单目标。
So we're going to go on the slide. And I'm very terrified right now because one wrong move, and I'm done.
我们要去滑滑梯。我现在非常害怕，因为只要错一步，我就完了。
And then she and her sister, Asele, grab their mats and push off.
然后她和妹妹阿塞尔抓起垫子冲了下去。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
Oh my god.
天哪。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The Varied Industries building is an enjoyable mishmash of t-shirts and household stuff for sale, but also expensive devices to help your blood circulation or your horse's blood circulation, plus, a guy in one of the more surprising missions at the fair, I thought.
综合工业大楼里陈列着各种各样的T恤和家居用品，也售卖昂贵的设备来帮助改善血液循环或你马匹的血液循环，此外，还有一个人带着博览会上更令人惊讶的任务，我是这么想的。
Now, this is--
现在，这是——
Marty Golden, in a neatly pressed blue uniform and Navy hat, was standing in front of a booth promoting the USS Iowa battleship, a World War II-era ship that's now a floating museum, its restoration paid for in part by grants from the state of Iowa.
马蒂·戈尔登身穿熨烫整齐的蓝色制服，头戴海军帽，站在一个宣传爱荷华号战列舰的摊位前，这是一艘二战时期的战舰，现在是一个漂浮博物馆，其修复费用部分由爱荷华州政府拨款资助。
We want to make the citizens of Iowa more aware of the battleship Iowa and let them know that anybody that's a resident of the state of Iowa gets on board the Iowa battleship for free. And if they let us know they're from Iowa, we'll take them behind the scenes to places that are not opened up to the general public.
我们想让爱荷华州公民更多地了解爱荷华号战列舰，并让他们知道，任何爱荷华州居民都可以免费登上这艘战舰。如果他们告诉我们他们来自爱荷华州，我们会带他们参观不对公众开放的幕后区域。
But there's a catch. Iowa happens to be landlocked. The ship is docked in Los Angeles, hence Marty's mission to get Iowans out there. Marty did two years in the Navy, 30 years in the Reserves. He served on a ship right off the coast of Havana during the Cuban Missile Crisis. He's also a marine biologist who studied ocean life, retired now. But he loved the Navy enough that now, he's a tour guide on the Iowa, which, again, is in the Port of Los Angeles. Marty is not an Iowan. He lives out there.
但有个条件。爱荷华州碰巧是个内陆州。这艘船停靠在洛杉矶，这就是马蒂的任务——让爱荷华人去那边。马蒂在海军服役了两年，在预备役服役了30年。在古巴导弹危机期间，他在哈瓦那海岸附近的一艘船上服役。他也是一名退休的海军生物学家，研究海洋生物。但他热爱海军，以至于现在在爱荷华号上担任导游，而这艘船再次强调，是在洛杉矶港。马蒂不是爱荷华人，他住在那里。
I miss the Navy so much that I volunteer now about once a week down on the battleship Iowa.
我非常怀念海军，以至于我现在每周都会在爱荷华号战列舰上做志愿者大约一次。
And they flew you out here?
他们飞你过来的？
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
More or less.
差不多吧。
Oh, you flew yourself out here.
哦，你是自己飞过来的。
I contributed a substantial amount of the effort to get out here.
我为能来到这里付出了相当多的努力。
So basically, you said, let me go and do this. It'll be fun. And they're like, great.
所以基本上，你说，“让我去干这个吧。会很有趣。”然后他们说，“太好了。”
Yeah, they probably would have covered all of my expenses, but I believe in the ship. And the ship is always struggling to bring money in to keep operating.
是的，他们本可以承担我所有的费用，但我对这艘船有信念。而且这艘船一直都在为维持运营而筹集资金。
So you didn't want to take any money away that could have gone to the battleship?
所以你不想占用本可以用于战列舰的任何资金？
Correct.
没错。
The Iowa State Fair began in 1854, just eight years after Iowa became a state. They hadn't even picked a location to build their State Capitol building yet, but they wanted to come together for a fair, for reasons that aren't that different from why we do it today. And what are they?
爱荷华州博览会始于1854年，就在爱荷华州成为州后的仅仅八年。他们当时甚至还没有选好建造州议会大厦的地点，但他们想聚在一起参加博览会，原因和我们今天举办的原因没什么不同。它们是什么？
I think at a state fair, so much of what's on exhibit is us. We come, with the animals we raised, and our pies and sewing projects, our spelling bee skills, and our expertise at shooting balloons from horseback, and our love for a Navy museum battleship that we think others would love also if we could just tell them about it in person.
我认为在州博览会上，大部分展出的就是我们自己。我们带着养大的动物、派饼、缝纫作品、拼字比赛技能，以及骑马射击气球的专业知识，还有对一艘海军战列舰博物馆的热爱来到这里，如果我们能亲自向别人介绍，我们相信别人也会喜欢的。
We take in the exhibits and we are the exhibits at a state fair. That's what's so different about a state fair from everything else. Today, we hang out with some of the one million people at the fair and see if they get what they wanted and dreamed of from the fair this year. From WBEZ Chicago, This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们在州博览会上观看展览，而我们自己也是展览的一部分。这就是州博览会与其他一切事物的不同之处。今天，我们将与博览会上的那一百万人中的一些人待在一起，看看他们是否得到了他们今年对博览会的期许和梦想。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
This American Life, Act One, Carney Confidential. So Bailey Leavitt has a different relationship to state fairs and carnivals from most of us.
《美国生活》，第一幕，嘉年华内部秘密。贝利·利维特与大多数人对州博览会和嘉年华的感受不同。
It always feels good to be back on a midway. When I come out here, I smell it. It just feels like home to me.
回到嘉年华场地总会让人感觉很好。当我来到这里，闻到那种气味，感觉就像回到了家。
Bailey grew up in carnivals, comes from a family of carnies.
贝利在嘉年华长大，来自一个嘉年华表演者家族。
Wait, I'm smelling. What is the smell you're talking about?
等等，我闻到了。你说的气味是什么？
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
So I smell turkey legs, for sure. I could smell the cotton candy, that burnt sugar smell. And there's always an underlying kind of grease smell, the diesel smell from the rides and from the generator, which is giving power to all the rides. It's so comforting to me.
我肯定闻到了火鸡腿的味道。我能闻到棉花糖，那种焦糖的味道。而且总是有一种潜在的油脂味，那种来自游乐设施和发电机的柴油味，为所有的设施供电。这对我来说非常令人安心。
Bailey read on Instagram that we were going to be doing this show about state fairs and she wrote in, talking about her family's life on the road as carnies, mostly out west. I thought it would be fun to walk through the midway with her and see it through her eyes, because she notices all kinds of stuff, big and little, that you and I don't know enough to notice. She grew up with a different vocabulary for everything around us here. She calls all the games joints.
贝利在Instagram上看到我们将要制作关于州博览会的节目，她写信进来，讲述了她家人作为嘉年华表演者在路上的生活，大多是在西部。我想和她一起走过嘉年华场地，通过她的眼睛来看它，因为她注意到了我们不知道去注意的各种各样的大小事物。她从小就对我们周围的一切有不同的词汇。她管所有的游戏叫“摊位”。
Well, it's a four-sided joint, but then three sides--
嗯，这是一个四面的摊位，但有三面——
Cotton candy stands are poppers. Food stands are grabs. Prizes are flash. Carnivals themselves are shows, as in--
棉花糖摊位叫“弹出式摊位”。食品摊位叫“抓取区”。奖品叫“闪光品”。嘉年华本身叫“演出”，就像——
He's actually still on that show. And I think he's managing rides now.
他实际上还在那个演出中。我想他现在在管理游乐设施。
--a bunch of different shows. 13 independent companies provide the games and rides for the Iowa State Fair. We walk up to a balloon game that must be, I don't know, 20, 25 feet tall, a structure made from aluminum scaffolding with flags and prizes hanging everywhere, and two giant banners saying, bust one wins. Bailey gives it a once over. She's impressed.
——一系列不同的演出。13家独立公司为爱荷华州博览会提供游戏和游乐设施。我们走到一个气球游戏摊位前，它一定有20、25英尺高，结构由铝制脚手架组成，到处悬挂着旗帜和奖品，还有两个巨大的横幅写着“打中一个就赢”。贝利仔细打量了一下。她印象深刻。
You can tell that they take good care of the joint because you see how clean all this stuff is, where all those connection points are?
你可以看出他们非常爱护这个摊位，因为你看这些东西有多干净，所有这些连接点在哪里？
You're pointing to the frame of the stand itself.
你是指摊位本身的框架。
Yeah, the joints where different pieces link up for this game. All that stuff is really well maintained.
是的，不同部件连接在一起玩这个游戏的接点。所有这些东西都维护得非常好。
Bailey tries to spot who's green help and who's a 40 miler-- that means just there for a bit-- and who's a genuine carny. Before I met Bailey, I honestly wasn't so sure if people still use the word carny or if it has some sort of derogatory, old-timey feeling to it. She told me some carnies hate the word, but she and her family embrace it with pride. These days, Bailey works for a little software company that her mom started.
贝利试图辨认谁是“新手”，谁是“四十英里路客”——意思只是在那儿待一会儿——以及谁是真正的嘉年华表演者。在见到贝利之前，我真的不确定人们是否还在使用“嘉年华表演者”（carny）这个词，还是它带有一种贬义的、老旧的感觉。她告诉我一些表演者讨厌这个词，但她和她的家人骄傲地拥抱它。这些天，贝利在她妈妈创办的一家小软件公司工作。
Two of Bailey's brothers and her sister are still on the show, and her dad and stepmother were in a show in Alaska that her dad tries to pull her back into now and then. Bailey has happy memories growing up, running around carnivals and state fairs. She could ride any ride or play any game for free, surrounded by adults, her parents' employees, who kept their eyes on her. There were incredibly special days, like stock day, when the stuffed animals for the fair, the stock, would arrive on a giant semi-trailer truck.
贝利的两个兄弟和一个妹妹还在演出中，她的父亲和继母在阿拉斯加的一个演出里，她父亲偶尔想把她拉回去。贝利有快乐的童年回忆，在嘉年华和州博览会上到处跑。她可以免费玩任何设施或游戏，被成年人们包围，那些她父母的员工会看着她。有特别的日子，比如进货日，当博览会的填充玩具——“库存品”——会装在巨大的半挂卡车上到达时。
And it was a giant pile of toys that I could literally jump in and swim in like a ball pit, but with stuffed animals. That was my favorite.
那是一大堆玩具，我真的可以跳进去，像在球池里一样游泳，但那是填充玩具。那是我最喜欢的。
Bailey started to work in the fair for real when she was 10, working a goldfish game.
贝利10岁时开始正式在博览会上工作，经营一个金鱼游戏。
A four-sided center joint.
一个四面的中心摊位。
Bailey's mom, Tyna, joined us for a while in the midway. She was watching Bailey's baby while Bailey and I walked around. Tyna co-managed the family carnival for years and jokes that her kids learned to count by counting money. Says Bailey was great at drawing a crowd, loved the attention, loved performing. When she was little, her flaw as an employee? She did not care about convincing people to spend more money on the game.
贝利的妈妈泰娜和我们在嘉年华场地待了一会儿。她在照顾贝利的宝宝，我和贝利则四处走动。泰娜多年来共同管理家庭嘉年华，开玩笑说她的孩子们学会数数就是通过数钱。她说贝利很擅长吸引人群，喜欢受关注，喜欢表演。当她小的时候，她作为员工的缺点是什么？她不在乎说服人们在游戏上花更多的钱。
She would sit there and talk to people. And sometimes, she would get in trouble because, if she's talking to people, she's not actually making money. She's just talking to people. But then as she got older, she focused a little bit better, but--
她会坐在那儿和人聊天。有时，她会惹上麻烦，因为如果她在和人聊天，她实际上就没有在赚钱。她只是在聊天。但后来她长大了一点，注意力集中了一些，但是——
Weird that your child labor didn't pay off like you thought it would.
真奇怪，你的童工没有像你想象的那样带来回报。
Child labor laws do not apply to family, and they learn that very young.
童工法不适用于家庭，他们很小就学会了。
Yes. [LAUGHS]
是的。[笑声]
Is that true?
那是真的吗？
It is true. At least, that's what I told them. And they believed me.
那是真的。至少我是这么告诉他们的。他们也相信了。
Mom was actually right about that one. Something you don't think about too deeply as a civilian fairgoer, looking for fun, is that for the people working the fair, it really is all about money, how much you can make and how quickly and efficiently you can bring it in. Among other things, a state fair is a collection of small businesses attracted by the massive crowds. And among the people like Bailey, who work games and rides, the workers who make the most money are called agents.
妈妈在这件事上确实说对了。作为寻求乐趣的平民游客，你不会深思的一件事是，对于在博览会工作的人来说，这确实全是关于钱，你能赚多少钱，以及你多快多有效地能把它赚到手。除其他事项外，州博览会是由大量人群吸引来的小型企业集合。在像贝利这样经营游戏和游乐设施的人中，赚钱最多的员工被称为“代理人”。
The word "agent" means different things in different regions of the country among carnies. But where Bailey was a carny, agents were just the best there was, so good at getting families and guys trying to impress their girlfriends to throw money at games that carnival owners would pay them more than anybody else, and they would jump from show to show. They're agents, as in free agents. As we walk through the fairgrounds, the thing that Bailey wanted to show me more than anything was an agent.
“代理人”这个词在全国嘉年华表演者中有不同的含义。但在贝利当表演者的地方，代理人就是最优秀的，他们非常擅长让家庭和想给女朋友留下深刻印象的男生在游戏上掷钱，以至于嘉年华老板付给他们的钱比其他人多得多，而且他们会从一个演出跳到另一个演出。他们是代理人，就像自由球员一样。当我们走过展览场地时，贝利最想让我看的就是一个代理人。
Yeah, so an agent is someone who can do what we call putting a mark to sleep, where they're going to be able to kind of put you in this state where alls you want to do is continue playing their game. You want to work towards whatever prize they have you working towards, whether it's popping balloons, or knocking over milk bottles, or whatever. You're going to spend way more money than you planned on at that game. And whenever you get somebody in that state, if you're able to do it really well, it's called putting a mark to sleep.
是的，所以代理人是那种能做到我们所说的“让顾客进入睡眠状态”的人，他们能够让你进入一种状态，让你只想继续玩他们的游戏。你想要朝着他们让你奋斗的任何奖品努力，无论是打气球，还是打翻奶瓶，等等。你会花比计划多得多的钱在那个游戏上。每当你让某人进入那种状态，如果你能做得非常好，这就叫“让顾客进入睡眠状态”。
Bailey and her stepdad once watched an agent who put a mark to sleep so well that he spent all of his money, left the game, and then came back with more money.
贝利和她继父曾经看过一个代理人，他让顾客进入了完美的睡眠状态，以至于那人花光了所有的钱，离开了游戏，然后又带着更多的钱回来。
I'm getting chills as I talk about it. I've never seen anybody do that. Once a mark leaves your game, usually, they're awake and it's done.
当我谈到这个时，我感到背脊发凉。我从没见过任何人能做到那样。一旦顾客离开你的游戏，通常他们就清醒了，这就结束了。
I wanted to see this. I wanted to see an operator who put somebody to sleep. So we headed out in search of an agent.
我想看看这个。我想看一个让顾客进入睡眠状态的操作员。所以我们去寻找一个代理人。
There's going to be a lot of agents here.
这里会有很多代理人。
Come on up and come on in, guys. Who else wants to have some water gun fun today?
过来看看，进来吧，伙计们。今天还有谁想玩水枪游戏？
We head over to a game where there's a row of 14 chairs in front of 14 targets. The way this game works is you sit and fire a water pistol at the target. When you hit the bullseye, the water goes into a tube, filling it up. First player to fill their tube wins a stuffed doll.
我们去了一个摊位，前面有14个座位对着14个目标。这个游戏的运作方式是你坐下，用水枪射击目标。当你击中靶心时，水进入管子并将其填满。第一个填满管子的玩家赢得一个毛绒娃娃。
All right.
好了。
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
We got number one.
我们有一个第一名。
These long pauses you're hearing, Bailey disapproves.
你听到的这些长停顿，贝利很不赞同。
All right.
好了。
This guy's trying to get people to sit and play the game. Three players sit, then a fourth. 10 seats are empty.
这家伙试图让人们坐下来玩游戏。三名玩家坐下，然后是第四个。10个座位空着。
Last call for this race. At the sound of the bell, the water will start. Everybody ready in 3, 2, 1. Here we go. Go, go, go. All the way to the top. Keep your eye on this dot. Don't look up. It's water racing and water chasing today. Number eight, winner, winner, winner!
这是本场比赛最后一次叫人了。铃声一响，水就开始喷了。大家都准备好了吗，3，2，1。出发，去吧！一直射到顶端。盯着这个点。不要抬头。今天是水上竞速，水上追踪。8号，赢家，赢家，赢家！
So what do you think of him?
那你觉得他怎么样？
He's OK. He's not the best I've seen, but he's not the worst.
他还行。他不是我见过最好的，但也不是最差的。
He's doing good at trying to engage people and make them play, but he's had a lot of pauses where he's not talking at all.
他在努力吸引人们玩游戏方面做得不错，但他有很多停顿，什么都不说。
Bailey knows this particular game well, the water race. She's been the one on the mic running the water race for her dad's carnival in Alaska.
贝利很了解这个特定的游戏，水上竞速。她曾为她父亲在阿拉斯加的嘉年华在麦克风前经营水上竞速。
1 and 2.
1和2。
She was taught to do lots of rhyming when you're on the mic, lots of alliteration, like watch them race them, watch them chase them. That's one she did. This guy does not do much of that. Also--
她被教导在麦克风前要多用押韵，多用头韵，比如“看着他们赛跑，看着他们追逐”。那是她做过的一个。这家伙没怎么做这些。还有——
He's only getting three to four players each time.
他每次只招到三到四个玩家。
Do you think he can be pulling in more people?
你觉得他能拉到更多人吗？
Absolutely, yeah. It's a nice game. It has great stock. The joint looks really nice, really clean. But they could be making a lot more money, in my opinion.
绝对可以，是的。这是一个不错的游戏。它的奖品很好。摊位看起来非常漂亮，非常干净。但在我看来，他们本可以赚更多的钱。
Do you think this guy is an agent?
你觉得这家伙是代理人吗？
No, definitely not.
不，绝对不是。
We cross the fairgrounds, find another water race game, and this one's huge and beautiful, 26 seats instead of 14 like the first one. It's what Bailey calls a double-sided joint. There are two rows of chairs facing each other, and the guy on the mic stands in the middle on a platform between the two rows. Huge, fluffy prizes hanging everywhere. And the guy on the mic--
我们穿过展览场地，找到了另一个水上竞速游戏，这一个又大又漂亮，26个座位，而不是第一个那样的14个。这就是贝利所说的“双面摊位”。两排椅子面对面，麦克风前的人站在两排之间的平台上。巨大的毛绒奖品随处可见。而麦克风前的那个人——
Get ready, get set, go, go, go, go. All right, don't waste the drippity drop trying to get to the tippity top. Stop, watch, and see. Who's it going to be? And the winner is--
准备好，各就各位，出发，出发，出发，出发。好了，别在去往顶端的路上浪费那一点点水。停下，观看，看看。会是谁？赢家是——
Right there, all that rhyming, the alliteration.
就在那儿，所有的押韵，头韵。
Alliteration.
头韵。
Yeah.
是的。
Number 18, winner, winner, winner.
18号，赢家，赢家，赢家。
He's constantly talking. He's using a lot of alliteration, and rhyming, and catchy things to draw people in.
他一直在说话。他使用了大量的头韵、押韵和吸引人的东西来吸引人们。
Even I can tell, this guy's got charisma. He's a stocky, bald guy with a five o'clock shadow. When he's on the mic, you cannot look away.
即使是我也能看出，这家伙很有魅力。他是一个结实的秃头男人，有着浓密的胡茬。当他在麦克风前时，你无法移开视线。
You guys ready?
你们准备好了吗？
And that great, gruff, rock and roll voice.
还有那美妙、粗犷、摇滚的声音。
Get ready, get set, go, go, go. Who's it going to be? Stop, watch, and see. Oh, man. It's close. It's neck to neck. It's toe to toe. Don't waste the drippity drop. Winner, winner, winner, winner, winner, winner, winner, winner, winner, winner, winner, chicken dinner.
准备好，各就各位，出发，出发，出发。会是谁？停下，观看，看看。噢，天哪。很接近。旗鼓相当。别浪费那一点点水。赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，鸡肉晚餐。
Yeah, this setup is great. They've got really hyped up music, flashing lights. They also got their mic turned up, so his voice is a lot more clear than that other guy.
是的，这个设置太棒了。他们有非常劲爆的音乐，闪烁的灯光。他们的麦克风音量也调大了，所以他的声音比那个人清晰得多。
Didn't want to do that quick, huh? All right, let's see.
不想做那个快动作，是吧？好吧，让我们看看。
And he's playing off his customers. He's joking around with them.
他在与顾客互动。他在和他们开玩笑。
Do it again. All right.
再做一次。好了。
Yeah, he's good at what he does.
是的，他很擅长自己的工作。
Look it, brother.
看这里，兄弟。
Bailey's mom, former carnival manager, she's watching him, too.
贝利的妈妈，前嘉年华经理，她也在看着他。
He's not a 40-miler. He's a carny.
他不是“四十英里路客”。他是嘉年华表演者。
Come on.
快点。
I do get the guy to talk to me in little snatches of conversation while winners are picking their prizes. His name is Jeremy Buvier.
在赢家挑选奖品时，我确实让这家伙跟我聊了几句简短的对话。他叫杰里米·布维耶。
How long have you been doing this?
你干这行多久了？
24 years.
24年。
How many months of the year do you work?
你一年工作几个月？
All year.
全年。
Winner, winner, winner.
赢家，赢家，赢家。
You work all year. Do you have a house or apartment somewhere that's yours?
你全年工作。你在某个地方有属于自己的房子或公寓吗？
I had an apartment up until January. I got tired of paying for it because I'm always gone. I'm buying a motor home in November.
直到一月我还有个公寓。我厌倦了付房租，因为我总是外出。我十一月要买一辆房车。
So if you have a motor home, then you just take the motor home with you as you travel?
所以如果你有房车，你旅行时就带着它？
Yep.
是的。
What city was the apartment in?
公寓在哪个城市？
Lewiston, Maine. That's where I'm from.
缅因州的刘易斯顿。我是那里人。
And who do you travel with?
你和谁一起旅行？
I go-- I bounce around.
我到处乱跑。
Bounce around. So this isn't-- you don't just travel with this ride?
到处乱跑。所以你不是只跟着这个游乐设施旅行？
No.
不。
And you're staying in bunks here?
你住在这里的铺位吗？
No, I stay at hotels.
不，我住酒店。
So you're doing good?
所以你干得不错？
Yes.
是的。
What percentage are they paying you of the gross here?
他们支付给你这里总收入的百分之多少？
I can't tell you that. It's good money, though.
我不能告诉你。不过是笔不错的钱。
So are you an agent?
所以你是代理人吗？
Pretty much. All right, I got to get back to work, though.
差不多吧。好了，我得回去工作了。
He's with it. He's an agent. You heard him talking about how he floats around and he just goes to different shows, he doesn't travel with any particular show-- that's all agent stuff. Staying in hotels-- agent. Agent all the way. Not talking about money-- agent. That's all agent moves.
他完全懂行。他是代理人。你听他说他是怎么到处漂泊，去不同的演出，不随特定的演出旅行——那全是代理人的行径。住酒店——代理人。完全是代理人。不谈钱——代理人。那全是代理人的套路。
So we saw an agent. But the truth is, we never got to see him really do his thing full force, because it was after 8:00 PM. This section of the fair, kiddieland, was dying down. So he never filled more than half the seats in his game. We didn't see him put anybody to sleep and keep them playing and spending money.
所以我们看到了一位代理人。但事实是，我们从没看到他真正全力以赴，因为那时已经晚上8点了。博览会的这一部分——儿童乐园——正在沉寂下来。所以他从来没有填满游戏里的半数以上座位。我们没看到他让任何人进入睡眠状态，并让他们持续玩耍和花钱。
But there was one more person Bailey and I watched. He was not, strictly speaking, a fellow carny. He was a salesman, a traveling salesman. But Bailey and I both watched him, mesmerized. And he was in one of the prime spots that anybody could possibly get at this state fair for selling anything.
但贝利和我还看了另一个人。严格来说，他不是嘉年华表演者。他是一名推销员，巡回推销员。但贝利和我都被他迷住了。他在这个州博览会上拥有任何卖东西的人都能得到的最佳位置之一。
This was outside the Varied Industries building, next to the door, and also the corner of the building. So you saw him approaching from two different directions. The Iowa State Fair charges a bunch of extra money for that spot, of course. This guy was calmly making bank-- Kenny Burnell. He sells nozzles for garden hoses.
这就在综合工业大楼外面，在门口旁边，也是大楼的拐角处。所以你看到人们从两个不同方向走近他。当然，爱荷华州博览会为那个位置收取了额外的费用。这家伙在平静地赚大钱——肯尼·伯内尔。他卖花园软管的喷嘴。
Well, I have them in any color you want as long as it's green.
嗯，只要是绿色的，你想要什么颜色我都有。
Some agents, Bailey says, are high-energy, but some are the opposite. They win through calm. That's Kenny. And OK, just to describe his setup, he's standing next to a clear glass box that's maybe two feet by two feet by two feet, spraying water into it with a garden hose, whose nozzle Kenny twists clockwise or counterclockwise to make the spray bigger or smaller.
贝利说，有些代理人精力充沛，但有些则相反。他们通过冷静获胜。那就是肯尼。好吧，描述一下他的设置，他站在一个大约两英尺见方的透明玻璃箱旁边，用花园软管往里面喷水，肯尼顺时针或逆时针扭动喷嘴，使喷雾变大或变小。
Going from left to right, you're going to have a little soft soak for potted plants. You've got a heavy rinse. You can get the house, the car, the windows. You got a wide fan. As you turn it, we'll go down to a pinpoint jet spray that'll clean the windows, the siding, and the gutters. And last but not least, you get a fine mist for delicate plants. That way--
从左到右，你会有一个给盆栽植物的轻柔浸泡。你有一个强力冲洗。你可以洗房子、汽车、窗户。你有一个宽扇形。当你转动它，我们会调到细针式喷射，能清洁窗户、壁板和排水沟。最后但并非最不重要的是，你得到一个给娇嫩植物的细雾。那样——
This guy, he puts people to sleep. He's putting marks to sleep. That's what he's doing.
这家伙，他让人进入睡眠状态。他在让顾客进入睡眠状态。这就是他在做的。
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
And he's good at it. Even his voice is kind of hypnotic, kind of getting them in the zone.
而且他做得很好。即使他的声音也带有一种催眠感，引导他们进入那种状态。
We stare at him as he puts people to sleep.
我们盯着他让人们进入睡眠状态。
And if you guys need a second one for the backyard, we do two for 75. You guys like to feel it as well.
如果你们后院需要第二个，我们买两个75块。你们也喜欢感受一下。
We bought one, then we bought another. Now we're going to buy another.
我们买了一个，然后又买了一个。现在我们又要买一个。
Thank you. I appreciate that.
谢谢。我很感激。
He's got a great visual presentation, but he's just really-- he has a really calm energy. And so you feel like this is a comforting guy, safe. So yeah, of course he's going to make the sale.
他有很好的视觉演示，但他就是真的——他有一种非常冷静的能量。所以你觉得这是一个令人舒适的人，安全。所以是的，他当然会成交。
With every new group of customers, Kenny hits the product against the ground to show how durable it is. He makes the same jokes.
每来一组新顾客，肯尼就把产品撞向地面以显示它的耐用性。他讲同样的笑话。
And I have them in any color you want as long as it's green.
只要是绿色的，你想要什么颜色我都有。
No purple?
没有紫色的吗？
No purple yet.
目前还没有紫色的。
When he gets a minute between customers to talk, Kenny Burnell tells me that his grandfather sold at state fairs, and his father. His own first memory of selling is doing a salsa maker demo at the Colorado State Fair one time with his dad when he was five and a half. He enjoyed it. When he was 10, he toured with his parents to state fairs and had his own booth, selling radio-controlled cars. As he got older, he learned to demo kitchen products.
当他在顾客之间有时间聊天时，肯尼·伯内尔告诉我他的祖父在州博览会上卖东西，他的父亲也是。他自己的第一段销售记忆是五岁半时和父亲在科罗拉多州博览会上做一个莎莎酱制作机的演示。他很喜欢。10岁时，他随父母去各州博览会巡回，拥有自己的摊位，卖无线电遥控车。随着年龄增长，他学会了演示厨房产品。
--and was pretty decent at it. But in my early teens, I was like, my heart's really not into kitchen gadgets, just not something I felt. And then I took a liking to this product. And I was like, I want to sell that.
——而且做得还不错。但在我十几岁初期，我就觉得，我的心真的不在厨房小工具上，那不是我感觉到的东西。然后我喜欢上了这个产品。我就说，我想卖那个。
He wanted to sell that because it has a great visual pitch. It's a quick pitch. Also, the water is loud. It's attention-getting. There's a wow moment when you hit the jet spray. And there's another wow moment when you go to the mist. And another advantage of these things? They're tiny.
他想卖那个，因为它有很棒的视觉推销。这是一个快速的推销。而且水声很大。很引人注目。当你调到喷射模式时有一个惊喜时刻。当你调到喷雾模式时，有另一个惊喜时刻。这些东西的另一个优点是什么？它们很小。
You can fit a whole fair's worth of inventory on one pallet.
你可以在一个托盘上装下整个博览会的库存。
A quick trade show-- he can check all the nozzles he needs into a carry on bag. Way better, he says, than when he sold pillows. It was 24 years ago when he started selling these. Some of his moves today, of course, he doesn't stop talking. Of course, he puts the product in the customer's hand. That's something he saw his dad do.
一个快速贸易展——他可以把他需要的所有喷嘴装进一个手提行李袋里。他说，这比他卖枕头时好多了。那是24年前他开始卖这些东西的时候。他今天的一些动作，当然，他不停地说话。当然，他把产品放在顾客手中。那是他看他父亲做的。
He's learned that to talk for 12 hours straight for a week and a half for a state fair, to preserve his voice, he'll consciously pitch it a little higher or a little lower for stretches at a time. Here in the Midwest, and also in certain cities like Seattle, he said, he mostly does not make direct eye contact during the pitch. I noticed that.
他学会了为了在州博览会上连续一周半每天工作12小时，为了保护嗓子，他会有意识地在一段时间内把音调稍微调高或调低。他说，在中西部，以及像西雅图这样的某些城市，他在推销时大多不直接进行眼神接触。我注意到了。
I was taught and raised to always make direct eye contact. What I found nowadays is I'll make eye contact roughly three times a demo. That's what I aim for-- one in the beginning, one in the middle, one right at the end when you're explaining the warranty and how much they are, but not too much, because I've done that a few times at this fair, where I'm making-- I'm demoing and doing it East Coast style. I'm making direct eye contact, and you can see them kind of looking off down the aisle. And they're just intimidated. And I don't want that. It's--
我受到的教育是总是进行直接的眼神接触。我现在发现，我在演示期间大约会进行三次眼神接触。这就是我的目标——开始时一次，中间一次，最后当你解释保修和价格时一次，但不能太多，因为我在这次博览会上做了几次，我在演示并使用东海岸风格。我进行直接的眼神接触，你可以看到他们有点看着过道远处。他们只是感到被恐吓了。我不想要那样。它是——
It's too aggressive to do the eye contact.
眼神接触太具攻击性了。
It's too aggressive, yeah.
太具攻击性了，是的。
Kenny, this is Bailey, who's worked a ton of fairs, a ton of carnivals.
肯尼，这位是贝利，她做过大量的博览会和嘉年华。
I grew up in the carnivals. So I just think you're great at what you do.
我在嘉年华长大。所以我只是觉得你很擅长你的工作。
Thank you. I appreciate that.
谢谢。我很感激。
Yeah.
是的。
And then they got into a little chat about headset microphones. Bailey wanted to know why he didn't use one. Kenny was like, I usually do, but I had a problem with my mic and then a problem with my backup mic. Bailey was sympathetic. They liked each other. Game recognizes game. In my line of work, I have to say, putting somebody to sleep means you are not doing your job right. It's one of the worst things you can say to somebody.
然后他们开始聊起了耳机麦克风。贝利想知道他为什么不用。肯尼说，我通常会的，但我麦克风出了点问题，然后备用麦克风也出了问题。贝利很同情。他们互相欣赏。高手识高手。在我的工作领域，我必须说，让某人进入睡眠状态意味着你没把工作做好。这是你能对某人说的最糟糕的事情之一。
When I told Kenny that's what Bailey said about him, he laughed and decided to take it as the compliment it was. He ended up selling $33,000 worth of nozzles over the course of the fair. That's 877 nozzles in 11 days, or put another way, for 12 hours a day, every single day, Kenny sold an average of one hose nozzle every 10 minutes.
当我告诉肯尼这就是贝利对他的评价时，他笑了，并决定把它当作一种赞美。博览会期间，他最终卖出了价值33,000美元的喷嘴。那是11天里877个喷嘴，或者换句话说，每天12小时，每一天，肯尼平均每10分钟卖出一个软管喷嘴。
Coming up, we go on a roller coaster of sorts, one filled with bunnies. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，我们要去坐某种过山车，上面全是兔子。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "Meet Me at the Fair," we hang out with some of the 1.2 million people who came to the Iowa State Fair this year to see if they got what they hoped for-- and we'll get back to that in a second. But first, let me tell you a story. Back in 2013, the band Motley Crue was getting older. One of its founding members had gotten a degenerative disease. The drummer, Tommy Lee, was going around saying they wanted to stop doing shows before they had to start replacing bandmates.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“在博览会相见”，我们与今年来到爱荷华州博览会的120万人中的一些人待在一起，看看他们是否得到了他们所希望的——我们很快会回到那个话题。但首先，让我给你们讲个故事。回到2013年，克鲁小丑乐队（Motley Crue）正在变老。其创始人之一患上了一种退行性疾病。鼓手汤米·李到处说他们想在不得不开始更换乐队成员之前停止演出。
That's such a bad look, when bands are still playing the [BLEEP] fairgrounds.
当乐队还在那些[哔——]博览会上演出时，那样子真是太差了。
A year later, Tommy Lee said, we are not playing county fairs. But Wednesday night, at the Iowa State Fair this year, Motley Crue played. They rocked. Fans partied.
一年后，汤米·李说，我们不在县博览会上演出。但今年周三晚上，在爱荷华州博览会上，克鲁小丑乐队演出了。他们很震撼。粉丝们狂欢。
Legalize cocaine! Hell yeah!
让可卡因合法化！太棒了！
[SHOUTING]
[呐喊声]
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
How was the show?
演出怎么样？
Huh?
啊？
How was the show?
演出怎么样？
Dude, I'm so [BLEEP] drunk, I can't [BLEEP] remember that [BLEEP].
伙计，我[哔——]喝得太醉了，我[哔——]记不起来那个[哔——]。
Curious about what it is like for the band to do this thing that they had sworn repeatedly they would never, ever do, we asked for an interview. The band said yes. And then a day later, we were told they would still love to talk to us, with one condition. They would not discuss playing state fairs.
出于对乐队做这种他们一再发誓永远、永远不会做的事情的感受的好奇，我们请求采访。乐队答应了。但一天后，我们被告知他们仍然很乐意与我们交谈，有一个条件。他们不会讨论在州博览会上演出的事。
In other words, Motley Crue is chicken. So I just want to say to the band right now, our offer is still good. We actually do want to hear what this is like for you to do this. Reach out if you change your minds. And with that, we turn to Act Two of our show.
换句话说，克鲁小丑乐队是胆小鬼。所以我现在只想对乐队说，我们的提议仍然有效。我们确实想听听你们做这件事的感受。如果你改变主意，请联系我们。就这样，我们转到节目的第二幕。
Act Two, How Bad is Your Bunny? So many people who come to the fair arrive with dreams tied to farmyard animals. There are non-stop animal competitions in hundreds of categories, all 11 days of the fair. One of our co-workers, Dana Chivvis, went to watch the 4H rabbit competition. She had no idea what an emotional roller coaster it would turn out to be. The 4H rabbit program is meant to teach kids lessons about animal science, and breeding, and caretaking, which they do learn, along with some other lessons. Here's Dana.
第二幕，你的兔子有多糟？许多来到博览会的人带着与农场动物相关的梦想。博览会全11天，有数百个类别的动物比赛从未间断。我们的同事达娜·奇维斯去观看4H兔子比赛。她不知道这将是一场多么令人情绪波动的过山车。4H兔子项目旨在教孩子们关于动物科学、繁殖和照顾的课程，他们确实学到了，同时还有一些其他的教训。这是达娜。
The rabbit show takes place in an industrial building on the outskirts of the fair-- tin roof, beige, metal siding, no frills. Rabbits don't get the respect they deserve, except from the kids.
兔子比赛在博览会郊区的一栋工业建筑里进行——锡屋顶，米色，金属壁板，没有花哨的东西。兔子没有得到它们应有的尊重，除了孩子们。
Hello.
你好。
Hi.
嗨。
I'm Dana. What's your name?
我是达娜。你叫什么名字？
I'm Molly Fox.
我是莫莉·福克斯。
Molly has shown rabbits at the county fair before, but this is her first year at the state fair, the big time. She's waiting in line to present the incredibly fuzzy black rabbit in her arms, a breed called Lionhead, named for the poof of mane it's supposed to have around its head. This competition is about presentation skills, demonstrating your knowledge about your animal's breed to a panel of three judges. Molly tells me she's not nervous. She carries her bunny to the judges' table.
莫莉以前在县博览会上展示过兔子，但这在州博览会上是第一年，那是大舞台。她排队准备展示她怀里那只极其毛茸茸的黑兔子，一个叫“狮子头”的品种，以它头部周围应该有的鬃毛蓬松感而命名。这场比赛关于展示技能，向三名裁判展示你对你动物品种的知识。莫莉告诉我她不紧张。她抱着兔子走到裁判桌前。
All right, you may start whenever you are ready.
好了，你准备好时就可以开始。
Hi. My name is Molly Fox, I'm 12 years old, and I'm from Hamilton County. This is Onyx. He is a junior buck Lionhead, and his color is black. First, I'm going to check the ears. Let me find the ear tattoo. There's so much fluff.
嗨。我叫莫莉·福克斯，我12岁，来自汉密尔顿县。这是玛瑙（Onyx）。他是一只幼年狮子头公兔，颜色是黑色。首先，我要检查耳朵。让我找找耳朵纹身。毛太多了。
Molly flips Onyx onto his back and opens his little rabbit mouth so his teeth show. So she's checking for buck teeth, pegged teeth.
莫莉把玛瑙翻到背上，打开他小小的兔子嘴，露出牙齿。所以她在检查有没有龅牙、桩牙。
Malocclusion, wolf teeth, and broken or chipped teeth.
咬合不正、狼牙，以及破损或缺损的牙齿。
The goal here is for the kids to look for the things a veteran judge would look for if they were evaluating this rabbit. Molly runs through the checklist she memorized with her dad, ears, nose, teeth, and then wraps it up with this professional assessment.
这里的目标是让孩子们寻找资深裁判在评估这只兔子时会寻找的东西。莫莉复述了她和父亲一起背下的检查清单：耳朵、鼻子、牙齿，然后用专业的评估结束。
I would like to see more of the wool type of fur on his hind legs. But overall, he is a very-- he is an excellent rabbit.
我希望能看到他后腿上有更多羊毛类型的毛。但总体而言，他是一只非常——他是一只优秀的兔子。
Molly has learned her 4H lessons well. The judges have no questions. She gets 94 points out of 100. Most of the kids I meet are proud of their rabbits. They talk about how soft they are, how nice their markings are, except for Jillian King, who is 11 and who has absolutely had it with her rabbit.
莫莉很好地学到了4H课程。裁判没有问题。她得了94分（满分100）。我遇到的大多数孩子都为他们的兔子感到自豪。他们谈论兔子有多软，标记有多好，除了吉莉安·金，她11岁，已经完全受够了她的兔子。
Because he's molting and he's really ugly right now. So I could get rid of him.
因为它正在换毛，现在真的很丑。所以我可以摆脱它。
Oh, babe.
哦，宝贝。
That sounds bad, but it's true.
听起来很坏，但这是真的。
It sounds awful.
听起来太糟糕了。
He needs more hair. He doesn't match breed standards. He's just the best rabbit I had for this right now.
它需要更多毛。它不符合品种标准。它只是我目前能拿出来的最好的兔子。
The rabbit in question is named Chacho. He's small and brown and has a bad case of bedhead, hair puffed out in all the wrong places, and a look that says he knows he screwed up.
有关的那只兔子叫查科（Chacho）。它又小又棕，头发乱蓬蓬，头发往错误的方向喷出，那一副表情仿佛在说它知道它搞砸了。
Oh, he's so cute though.
哦，但它还是很可爱。
He is cute, but not cute enough to be like that.
它是可爱，但还没可爱到那种程度。
What's his breed again?
它是什么品种来着？
Lionhead.
狮子头。
Oh, he's a Lionhead. I want to see the Lionheads.
哦，它是狮子头。我想看狮子头。
Well, there's better breed standards ones over here. He is not quite up to the best breed standard.
嗯，那边有品种标准更好的。它还没完全达到最佳品种标准。
So you said.
你刚才说过了。
But the better ones are over there.
但更好的在那边。
Jillian takes me a few rows over and points to two bunnies. And holy hell, I am telling you, these bunnies are some good-ass-looking bunnies, with that kind of calm demeanor that comes with effortless beauty. One is brownish-gray with dark brown ears that stick up in a regal way and hair that seems feline. The other one has a classically pretty bunny face, light brown, chubby cheeks, button nose. He's sitting up like a dog-- or like a bunny, I guess-- his eyes locked on the back of Chacho's fuzzy head.
吉莉安带我走过几排，指着两只兔子。天哪，我告诉你，这两只兔子真是非常好看的兔子，带着那种那种不费力的美带来的冷静风度。一只是棕灰色的，深棕色的耳朵以一种威严的方式竖着，毛发看起来像猫科动物。另一只拥有一张经典漂亮的兔脸，浅棕色，胖嘟嘟的脸颊，纽扣鼻子。它像狗一样坐着——或者我猜像兔子一样——眼睛锁定在查科毛茸茸的头后部。
Wow.
哇。
These two are very up to breed standards. They are gorgeous. They have a perfect mane, and skirt, and saddle, and everything that you should see.
这两只非常符合品种标准。它们非常华丽。它们有完美的鬃毛、裙毛、背毛，以及你应该看到的一切。
If you compare--
如果你比较——
Jillian holds Chacho up in front of these hot bunnies so I can see the difference.
吉莉安把查科举在这些火辣的兔子前面，这样我可以看到区别。
He should have a lot more hair. His hair didn't grow out as well, but he's also molting. So he's losing a lot of it right now, but it'll grow back.
它应该有更多的毛。它的毛没长得那么好，而且它还在换毛。所以它现在掉了很多，但会再长出来的。
He's going through an awkward phase right now, though. Poor guy.
它现在处于一个尴尬的阶段。可怜的小家伙。
But he's still not as good as these guys. These guys would beat him in a regular show. They would just easily beat him. They're just better.
但它仍然不如这些家伙。这些家伙在正规比赛中会赢它。它们会轻易赢它。它们只是更好。
Aw.
哎。
At the rabbit show, each rabbit is sized up against its breed standards. And then the judge awards the rabbit handler a ribbon. Confoundingly, purple is the best, followed by blue. A blue ribbon says your rabbit is up to breed standards, but isn't exceptional enough to get a purple. Next is red, which means your rabbit is a delinquent, and then white, which means you are a delinquent.
在兔子比赛中，每只兔子都要根据其品种标准进行衡量。然后裁判给兔子管理员发丝带。令人困惑的是，紫色是最好的，其次是蓝色。蓝色丝带表示你的兔子符合品种标准，但不够特殊而不能得到紫色。接下来是红色，意味着你的兔子是一个违规者，然后是白色，意味着你是一个违规者。
Jillian and her older sister Jenna are both having a bad "hare" day. Get it? Chacho is a mess. And Jenna's best rabbit, Martini, just got disqualified. Jenna is sitting in a camping chair in tears.
吉莉安和她的大姐姐珍娜都有糟糕的“兔子”天。懂了吗？查科是一团糟。珍娜最好的兔子，马天尼（Martini），刚被取消资格。珍娜坐在露营椅上流泪。
I'm Jenna.
我是珍娜。
Can I ask you what happened?
我可以问你发生了什么吗？
So I breed Harlequin rabbits. I was told one of my rabbits is sick, that her nose is running. And she's the best coloring I've got, and I don't know why she's sick. I'm just super disappointed right now.
所以我繁殖花斑兔。我被告知我的一只兔子病了，鼻子在流鼻涕。它是我想到的最好的颜色，我不知道为什么它会生病。我现在超级失望。
Disappointed and also worried. She loves this snotty rabbit. We walk over to Martini, who's lying across the back of her cage.
失望，但也担心。她爱这只鼻涕兮兮的兔子。我们走到马天尼身边，它躺在笼子后面。
That's Martini.
那是马天尼。
She's beautiful.
它很漂亮。
Yeah.
是的。
She has black and white bands across her body, and a perfect face split, which is to say, half her muzzle is white and half is black, a very desirable trait in a Harlequin rabbit.
它身体上有黑白带，还有一个完美的面部分裂，也就是说，它一半的嘴是白的，一半是黑的，这是花斑兔中非常令人向往的特征。
She's not happy.
它不高兴。
To my untrained eye, she seems pissed. Jenna says Martini and her sister, Tequila, don't really like people. She bred them herself, choosing to pair a rabbit named Whiskey with good coloring to a lady rabbit named Fawn, who has a great face split. Out of that blessed union, Martini was born.
在我这外行看来，它似乎很生气。珍娜说马天尼和她的妹妹龙舌兰（Tequila）真的不喜欢人。她是自己繁殖它们的，选择把一只叫威士忌（Whiskey）的颜色好的公兔和一只叫小鹿（Fawn）的、有完美面部分裂的母兔配对。在那神圣的结合中，马天尼出生了。
It was the week that things got really cold in January, like, negative 40. Half of her litter did not make it. It really sucked. But her mom got two of them through, which is good. So she's like a little miracle rabbit.
那是一月天气变得非常冷的一周，比如零下40度。它的一半兄弟姐妹没活下来。那真的很糟。但它的妈妈让其中的两只活了下来，这很好。所以它就像一只小小的奇迹兔子。
Was that really sad?
那真的很令人难过吗？
Yeah. It was my first litter, too. So that was a little bit rough, but you can't let it hold you back. You only get better the farther along you go. You can't really quit in the beginning.
是的。那也是我的第一窝。所以这有点艰难，但你不能让它阻碍你。你走得越远，你只会变得越好。你不能真的一开始就退出。
Well, I guess you could if you wanted, but--
嗯，我想如果你愿意的话你可以，但是——
Yeah, but--
是的，但是——
Jenna and I have a difference of opinion here. I'm totally for quitting, especially if the activity involves frozen bunnies. As we're admiring Martini, Jenna's mother, TJ, walks up with news.
珍娜和我在这一点上有不同意见。我完全支持退出，尤其是如果活动涉及冷冻的兔子。当我们欣赏马天尼时，珍娜的母亲TJ带着消息走过来。
She doesn't-- she's what?
它不——它是怎么了？
She's allergic to the sawdust. I just talked to that guy who said, hey, it's an allergy. They did--
它对锯末过敏。我刚和那个人谈过，他说，嘿，那是过敏。他们确实——
Martini is not sick. She does not have snuffles, which is rabbit sniffles. She's just allergic to the sawdust they put in all the rabbit cages at the fair. Jenna doesn't use sawdust at home, so she had no way of knowing this. She's crying again.
马天尼没生病。它没有“鼻涕症”（snuffles），即兔子感冒。它只是对博览会所有兔子笼子里放的锯末过敏。珍娜家里不用锯末，所以她没法知道。她又哭了。
That's so good to know.
那真是太好了。
Right. I said, we're learning things the hard way this year, and that sucks.
没错。我说，我们今年在用艰难的方式学习东西，这真糟。
I suspect the lesson TJ is referring to is don't put sawdust in a rabbit cage. But I could see another lesson appearing on the horizon, one about the inevitability of disappointment, how disappointment leads to growth, how you don't need some technocrat from the bunny industrial complex to hand you a ribbon to know in your heart that you've got an outstanding rabbit.
我怀疑TJ提到的教训是“不要在兔子笼子里放锯末”。但我可以看到另一个教训出现在地平线上，关于失望的不可避免性，失望如何导致成长，你不需要兔子工业联合体的官僚给你发丝带来确认你知道在内心深处拥有一只出色的兔子。
How does that make you feel? Better?
那让你感觉如何？好点了吗？
Yeah, way better. I really thought something might have happened and I didn't see it. I was kind of worried.
是的，好多了。我真的以为可能发生了什么事，而我没看到。我有点担心。
And they invited us to the show in Boone in October because she's a phenomenal rabbit. [LAUGHS]
他们邀请我们十月去布恩参加比赛，因为它是一只了不起的兔子。[笑声]
Yay.
耶。
Come here. Come here.
过来。过来。
They hug it out.
他们拥抱在一起。
I'm glad now that we know it's just an allergy. That makes me feel, again, 20 times better.
我现在很高兴我们知道这只是过敏。这让我再次感觉好20倍。
Did you just hear what they said over the loudspeaker?
你刚才听到扩音器里说什么了吗？
No.
没有。
For Harlequins? The best rabbit here today had to be disqualified.
花斑兔的？今天这里最好的兔子不得不被取消资格。
Understanding washes over Jenna's face. More tears.
理解浮现在珍娜脸上。更多的眼泪。
Don't cry. I'm going to cry for you. You know what that means? You know what it means?
别哭。我都要为你哭了。你知道那意味着什么吗？你知道它意味着什么吗？
I don't want to show Martini again when she's not hay chip sick.
我不想在马天尼没得干草片过敏时再展示它。
Yes. And that your breeding program is exactly on track where you want it to be. That is the moment you take away from this, that you did something phenomenal genetically. It's not about the show. I'm so proud. You be proud of that.
是的。而且你的繁殖计划正朝着你想要的轨道发展。这就是你从中学到的时刻，你从基因上做了一些了不起的事情。这与比赛无关。我太骄傲了。你要为此自豪。
I need some Kleenex.
我需要纸巾。
I know. Me too. I don't have any. Don't cry.
我知道。我也需要。我没有。别哭。
That's great. I'm excited to breed her now.
那太好了。我现在很兴奋繁殖它。
Jenna plans to match Martini with Mo, the rabbit in the cage next door, who's a few months younger than Martini and seems like a doofus. But I'm no expert.
珍娜计划把马天尼和莫（Mo）配对，那是隔壁笼子里的兔子，比马天尼小几个月，看起来像个笨蛋。但我不是专家。
And what about poor Chacho, Jillian's discombobulated rabbit? He ends up getting a red ribbon, which is second to worst, or if you ask Chacho, third best. Jillian's surprised.
那吉莉安那只被打乱的兔子可怜的查科呢？它最终得了一条红色丝带，这是倒数第二差的，或者如果你问查科，是第三好的。吉莉安很惊讶。
It was better than I was expecting.
这比我预期的要好。
Yeah, are you less mad at him now?
是的，你现在对他没那么生气了吗？
No, not really. I'm still getting rid of him. So he's cute, but he's not what I'm looking for to bring into my breeding program.
不，并没有。我还是打算摆脱他。所以他很可爱，但他不是我想带入繁殖计划的那种兔子。
The lesson Chacho takes home from the State Fair is show business isn't for everyone, but he has a happy retirement to look forward to. Jillian plans to sell him to a good home, where he'll be someone's pet-- or maybe better for Chacho, the young buck in someone else's probably unsuccessful breeding program.
查科从州博览会上学到的教训是：演艺圈并不适合所有人，但他有一个快乐的退休生活可以期待。吉莉安打算把它卖给一个好的家庭，在那儿它会成为某人的宠物——或者对查科来说更好，成为别人大概不成功的繁殖计划里的年轻公兔。
Dana Chivvis is a producer on our show. One quick program note before we go any further. Some of you may have noticed a word usage that you're getting ready to email us about. I just want to say right now, yes, we know that a hare is not the same thing as a rabbit. But can I say, puns breed around this office like punnies.
达娜·奇维斯是我们节目的制作人。在我们继续之前，有一条简短的节目通知。你们有些人可能注意到了一种用法，你们正准备发邮件给我们。我现在只想说，是的，我们知道野兔（hare）和兔子（rabbit）不是同一回事。但我能说吗，双关语在我们办公室就像兔子一样繁殖。
Act Three, Limp Biscuit. So every Iowan that I talked to outside the fair this year, when I mentioned that I was going to the fair, what we would end up talking about was food and what to eat. Food is a big thing at so many state fairs. News coverage of Iowa's fair always includes the latest stuff, like this year's bacon cheeseburger egg roll.
第三幕，跛脚饼干。所以我在博览会外采访的每一个爱荷华州人，当我提到我要去博览会时，我们最终谈论的话题就是食物和吃什么。食物是许多州博览会上的大事。爱荷华博览会的新闻报道总是包括最新的东西，比如今年那个培根芝士汉堡蛋卷。
There are nearly 200 food stands at the fair, and they rarely become available for people who want to try to create the next hit themselves. Those spots are highly coveted because there's so much money to be made. Fair's management says that some vendors earn their entire annual income for the year at those 11 days at the fair. Chris Benderev had followed one family that tried to jump into the game this year.
博览会上有近200个食品摊位，对于那些想尝试自己创造下一个爆款的人来说，这些摊位很少有空缺。这些位置非常令人垂涎，因为有太多的钱可以赚。博览会管理层说，一些摊主在那博览会的11天里赚到了他们全年收入的全部。克里斯·本德雷夫一直关注着今年试图加入游戏的一个家庭。
Of the handful of new food stands at the fair this year, it was obvious which one would be the most interesting to watch. It's run by a couple, Jamie and Jennifer Adkins. And as best as I can tell, they're different from the other food stand managers at the fair in one important way.
在今年博览会的少数几个新食品摊位中，很明显哪一个最值得关注。它是由一对夫妇，杰米和詹妮弗·阿德金斯经营的。据我所知，他们与博览会上其他食品摊位经理在一个重要方面有所不同。
So you guys have not run a restaurant before?
所以你们以前没经营过餐馆？
That's correct.
没错。
And you guys haven't run your own stand at another state fair before.
而且你们也没在另一个州博览会上经营过自己的摊位。
Correct. This is our first big gig.
正确。这是我们的第一次大型演出。
All the other new food stands in Iowa this year are owned and run by people in the restaurant business, or they've done other big fairs. So how did Jamie and Jennifer end up doing this? Well, for a long time, Jennifer had dreamt of opening her own coffee shop. Then her husband saw this opportunity, not to launch a coffee shop exactly, but to launch an 11-day-long state fair version of it.
今年爱荷华州所有其他新食品摊位都由餐饮业的人拥有和经营，或者他们做过其他大型博览会。所以杰米和詹妮弗是怎么最终做到这一点的？嗯，詹妮弗长期以来一直梦想开自己的咖啡店。然后她丈夫看到了这个机会，不是确切地开一家咖啡店，而是开一家为期11天的州博览会版本。
He heard about a food stand that was withdrawing from the state fair. They could save money by buying its used trailer and equipment. Jennifer could sell coffee drinks, and they'd do some food on the side-- biscuit sandwiches, they decided, because there aren't many vendors selling breakfast at the fair. And so they jumped in and prepared to launch Biscuit Bar. But when I talked to them in July, before the fair opened, they each had very different expectations for how much money they'd make.
他听说一个食品摊位要从州博览会撤出。他们可以通过购买其二手拖车和设备来省钱。詹妮弗可以卖咖啡饮料，他们会在旁边做些食物——饼干三明治，他们决定，因为博览会上没有多少摊主卖早餐。于是他们跳了进去，准备推出“饼干吧”（Biscuit Bar）。但当我在七月，在博览会开幕前与他们交谈时，他们对赚多少钱有着非常不同的预期。
I tend to be more frugal and conservative about finances, so I'm really just hoping to be able to help pay for some of the expenses that we've had. That's really what I'm hoping for.
我倾向于在财务上更节俭和保守，所以我真的只是希望能够帮助支付我们已经产生的一些费用。那确实是我所希望的。
Jennifer just wants to break even, cover all their costs, but she told me she didn't think they'd do that. The costs were too big. They'd spent $300,000 for the trailer and all the equipment. And that's before you get to salaries and food costs. Plus, the State Fair takes 19.5% of every dollar every food vendor brings in. Jamie, her husband, owns a successful trucking business. And when I reached him by phone, he was confident they'd make everything back this first year.
詹妮弗只是想收支平衡，覆盖他们所有的成本，但她告诉我她不认为他们能做到。成本太大了。他们花了30万美元买拖车和所有设备。那是在你支付工资和食品成本之前。此外，州博览会拿走每个食品摊主带来的每一美元的19.5%。杰米，她丈夫，拥有一家成功的运输企业。当我通过电话联系到他时，他很有信心他们第一年就能赚回一切。
It'll work. I guarantee that it'll work. No doubt about it. It'll work. It's just how much the profit is. My personal thought for this year was, I'd like to do about gross sales of $300,000, $350,000 on the minimum side. It's kind of like going to the casino. [LAUGHS] You go there to win. You just hope you win more than you lose.
它会成功的。我保证它会成功的。毫无疑问。它会成功的。只是利润多少的问题。我个人对今年的想法是，我希望能有总销售额30万到35万美元，按最低标准算。这有点像去赌场。[笑声]你去那是为了赢。你只是希望你赢的比输的多。
This kind of confidence, of course, is exactly what you'd need if you're an amateur and you decided you're going to get into any part of the restaurant business, a notoriously difficult business to make money in. But Jamie has a cousin, Joni, who runs two popular, very successful food stands at the fair. Jamie's helped her out a little in the past. And seeing his cousin's operation made the idea of raking in lots of cash seem way more possible, at least for him. Again, here's his wife, Jennifer.
当然，这种自信正是如果你是一个业余爱好者，并决定要进入餐饮业的任何部分——一个以赚钱困难而著称的行业——所需要的。但杰米的表妹乔尼在博览会上经营着两个受欢迎、非常成功的食品摊位。杰米过去帮过她一点忙。看到他表妹的经营让赚大钱的想法显得更有可能，至少对他来说是这样。再次，这里是他的妻子詹妮弗。
Probably for him, because it really looks effortless for her. She's just so good. And there's no way I'd ever be able to get up to her level. And I think for him, she really is inspiring, for sure. [LAUGHS]
对他来说可能这样，因为它对她来说看起来真的毫不费力。她太棒了。而且我永远无法达到她的水平。我想对他来说，她确实很有启发性，肯定的。[笑声]
Could that be almost a tricky thing because she makes it look deceptively simple?
这几乎是一件棘手的事情吗，因为它让她看起来极其简单？
Possibly, yes.
有可能，是的。
[CLATTER]
[金属撞击声]
6:30 AM, August 8, the first day of the fair. And this, employees scraping cooked food out of pots into storage containers, is the sound of a food stand about to debut itself to Iowa. The gates of the fair don't open until 8:00 AM, so let me give you a sense of the place. Right now, I'm in the open-air kitchen that's behind Biscuit Bar. This is where all the raw materials, meats and eggs and biscuits, are cooked, and then get passed into the trailer, where they're assembled into sandwiches. Everyone's calm. They're ready.
8月8日，早上6:30，博览会的第一天。而这个，员工把煮熟的食物从锅里刮到储存容器里，是一个食品摊位即将向爱荷华州首秀的声音。博览会大门直到早上8点才开，所以我让你感受一下这个地方。现在，我正在饼干吧后面的露天厨房。这就是所有的原材料——肉、鸡蛋和饼干——被烹饪，然后传送到拖车里，组装成三明治的地方。每个人都很冷静。他们准备好了。
Can I ask what you guys are doing at this point?
我可以问你们这个时候在做什么吗？
Cleaning tubs.
清理盆。
All our-- we got all our stuff made.
我们所有的——我们所有的东西都做好了。
The trailer Jamie and Jennifer paid hundreds of thousands of dollars for is gleaming, with a green and pink facade, emblazoned with real pictures of biscuit sandwiches, but also cartoons of friendly anthropomorphized biscuit sandwiches. The word "espresso" appears in four places. And then at the top, outlined with dots of neon lights in big letters, Biscuit Bar. There are three registers out front, each with a teenager behind it. Lily is the most chipper by far. She's ready to sell.
杰米和詹妮弗花了数十万美元买的拖车闪闪发光，有着绿色和粉色的外观，上面印着饼干三明治的真实图片，还有友好的拟人化饼干三明治的卡通图。单词“浓缩咖啡”（espresso）出现在四个地方。然后在顶部，用霓虹灯圆点勾勒出大字母，饼干吧。前面有三个收银机，每个后面都有一个少年。莉莉是目前为止最开朗的。她准备好卖东西了。
We're really excited to be here. We've got a couple of great new items. We have the Piggy in a Donut, which won an award, especially for our piggy--
我们真的很兴奋能来到这里。我们有一些很棒的新品。我们有“甜甜圈里的小猪”，它赢得了奖项，特别是为我们的“小猪”秘密酱——
Yes, our piggy secret sauce. It's kind of got a kick to it. It's got some chipotle in it. So if you're feeling something a little bit spicier, definitely, that's the way to go. We also have a Bubbly Latte, which is kind of like a hybrid between your--
是的，我们的“小猪”秘密酱。它有一种刺激的感觉。它里面有一些墨西哥辣椒。所以如果你想吃点更辣的，绝对，那是最好的选择。我们还有“气泡拿铁”，它有点像你——之间的混合体。
It's about 7:45 AM. Some of the people who are allowed in early, fair staff, people here to show livestock, they start lining up at Biscuit Bar, eager for breakfast and coffee. I find Jamie inside the trailer. He's got a buzzed head, goatee, gruff voice, but soft eyes. He's assembling coffee orders alongside one of his new employees.
现在大约是早上7:45。一些被允许早进入的人，博览会工作人员，在这里展示牲畜的人，开始在饼干吧排队，渴望早餐和咖啡。我在拖车里找到了杰米。他剃着平头，山羊胡，嗓音粗哑，但眼神柔和。他正和他的新员工之一一起组装咖啡订单。
What do you need?
你需要什么？
Trying to get me some coffee.
尝试给我点咖啡。
A small iced espresso.
小杯冰浓缩咖啡。
Vanilla, and add whipped topping. So it's a small?
香草味的，加生奶油顶。所以是小杯的？
Yeah.
是的。
They're both wearing these hot pink Biscuit Bar t-shirts. Everyone here is. And in this moment, I'm struck by how something as simple as matching t-shirts can create a unifying sense of shared fortune, of teamwork. It's almost beautiful to behold.
他们都穿着这些亮粉色的饼干吧T恤。这里的每个人都是。就在这一刻，我被简单的匹配T恤如何能创造一种统一的共享命运感、团队精神所打动。目睹这一切几乎很美。
The problem is that--
问题在于——
Wait, actually, there's some kind of issue with the espresso drink.
等等，实际上，浓缩咖啡饮料出了点问题。
See, it looks weak to me.
看，它对我来说看起来很淡。
That's what she was saying too.
她也是这么说的。
What is going on here?
这里发生了什么？
This iced drink looks weird. It tastes weird. Jamie starts inspecting the back side of the large espresso machine.
这杯冰饮看起来很奇怪。尝起来很奇怪。杰米开始检查大型浓缩咖啡机的背面。
See, I've always been intimidated by this thing.
看，我一直被这东西吓到了。
Somebody shut this switch off. That's why.
有人关了这个开关。这就是原因。
Oh.
哦。
It wasn't brewing because it's not hot. This is never supposed to get shut off, and somebody had shut it off.
它没有煮是因为它不热。这东西从来不应该被关掉，有人把它关了。
And the two pigs are done.
两只猪做好了。
It's going to probably take five or six minutes. Let's just see.
可能需要五六分钟。我们来看看。
When Jamie says it'll take five or six minutes for the water to reheat, he actually has no idea how long it'll take. A couple espresso drink orders are already waiting, and more are coming in. Five minutes pass. The water still isn't hot. Jamie shows Jennifer.
当杰米说水重新加热需要五六分钟时，他实际上根本不知道需要多久。已经有几杯浓缩咖啡订单在等着了，更多的还在进来。五分钟过去了。水还是不热。杰米给詹妮弗看。
The problem is that it's not hot, Jennifer. It's going to take five more minutes, probably.
问题在于它不热，詹妮弗。可能需要再过五分钟。
So we need a vanilla iced espresso?
所以我们需要一杯香草冰浓缩咖啡？
And there's fresh grounds in there ready to go, but the water isn't hot enough yet. So somebody shut the switch off on the bottom. I don't know what they was doing, but--
那里有新鲜的咖啡渣准备好了，但水还不够热。所以有人关了底部的开关。我不知道他们在干什么，但是——
Jamie leaves Jennifer to figure out the coffee. Meanwhile, the employees assembling the sandwiches inside the trailer are shouting out the window to the kitchen. They need supplies. Brisket for the brisket sandwich won't be ready for 20 more minutes. And there are other shortages.
杰米留詹妮弗去处理咖啡。与此同时，在拖车内组装三明治的员工正冲着窗户外的厨房大喊。他们需要补给。布里斯克特（brisket）三明治的肉需要再过20分钟才能好。还有其他短缺。
We got sausage gravy?
我们有香肠肉汁吗？
Sausage gravy.
我们可以直接在这里做。
Do we have more gravy made?
是的，它们不像其他的那样煮。它们简直痛得该死。
Nope.
没。
OK, well, then we need to be making gravy. Wow.
OK，那我们需要做肉汁。哇。
Or a little later--
或者晚一点——
Can we get sausage patties, please?
能给我们香肠饼吗，请？
What did she want?
她想要什么？
Sausage patties. Sausage patties.
香肠饼。香肠饼。
We better put some more on. Do you know where they're at?
我们最好多放一些。你知道它们在哪儿吗？
Jamie starts rummaging through the fridge, looking for more individually wrapped sausage patties. He started the day with just 80, and now they're almost out. Jamie does find a huge bag of raw sausage and gets people to start molding that into patties. His brother Jeff starts grilling them. Jamie feels like these handmade patties are a workable solution. Jeff, who is like a shorter version of Jamie with a dash of Joe Pesci mixed in, does not.
杰米开始在冰箱里翻找，寻找更多独立包装的香肠饼。他开始这一天时只有80个，现在几乎用光了。杰米确实找到了一大袋生香肠，让人们开始把那塑造成肉饼。他弟弟杰夫开始烤它们。杰米觉得这些手工肉饼是一个可行的解决方案。杰夫，像杰米较矮的版本，带有一点点乔·佩西（Joe Pesci）混合在里面，并不这么认为。
We can make them right here.
我们可以在这里直接制作它们。
Yeah, them don't cook like the other ones do. They're a pain in the fucking dick.
是啊，它们可不像别的那些好做。简直让人烦透了。
In case you didn't catch that, Jeff said the handmade patties are a pain in the fucking dick to cook.
以防你没听清楚，杰夫说手工肉饼烤起来痛得该死。
Because then you got to check every one of them because they're not the same thickness, not the same shape.
因为那样你就得检查它们每一个，因为它们厚度不一样，形状也不一样。
It'll be all right.
会没事的。
Jamie does have a secret card he can play in this situation. He phones up Joni, his cousin with the successful food stands, to see if she has extra patties.
杰米在这种情况下的确有一张秘密牌可以打。他打电话给乔尼，他在有成功食品摊位的表妹，看看她是否有额外的肉饼。
Hello? I think I'm going to run out of pork patties before I can get time to go to the kitchen and get what Josh dropped me. We are busy. We had a few people. Fucking Albert.
喂？我想我会在我有时间去厨房拿乔希送给我的东西之前用完猪肉饼。我们很忙。我们有几个人。该死的阿尔伯特。
Albert is the guy who was supposed to deliver the milk.
阿尔伯特是应该送牛奶的那个人。
Give me that milk.
把那牛奶给我。
Another problem.
另一个问题。
Must not have brought me whole milk. I'm going to fucking kill him. Told him 12 gallon of whole milk, and he brought me all skim.
一定没带给我全脂牛奶。我要杀了他。告诉他12加仑全脂牛奶，他全给我带了脱脂的。
This is a problem. You can't make gravy with skim milk.
这是一个问题。你不能用脱脂牛奶做肉汁。
Motherfucker. OK, bye.
妈的。好了，再见。
Meanwhile, out in front of the trailer, there's a semicircle of customers waiting for their orders. They all seem pretty calm, including Erika and Kris, two women who are wearing athleisure wear.
与此同时，在拖车前面，有一个半圆形的顾客在等他们的订单。他们看起来都很冷静，包括艾丽卡和克里斯，两个穿着休闲运动服的女人。
We're waiting.
我们在等。
Has it been a bit of a wait?
等了一会儿了吗？
Just a little bit, but that's OK. They're figuring things out.
稍微有一点，但没关系。他们正在处理事情。
Can I ask how long you've been waiting?
我可以问你们等了多久了吗？
Right now, we're at eight minutes.
现在，我们在等八分钟。
Back inside the big green and pink trailer--
回到那辆巨大的绿色和粉色拖车里——
Hey, we need another three piggies and a hot chick!
嘿，我们需要另外三个“小猪”和一个辣妹！
--it's very tight in the trailer. And to assemble sandwiches, people are constantly squeezing past each other because the sausage and biscuits and eggs are on one end, and the sauces and dressings and cheese are on the other. Then they drop the finished sandwiches, wrapped in foil, near the front window. But the problem is, there's nothing written on the foil. They all look alike, which is why one of the cashiers sticks his head in and asks me--
——拖车里非常挤。而且为了组装三明治，人们不断地挤过对方，因为香肠、饼干和鸡蛋在一端，酱料、调料和奶酪在另一端。然后他们把做好的三明治放在前窗附近，用锡纸包好。但问题是，锡纸上没写任何东西。它们看起来都一样，这就是为什么其中一个收银员把头探进来问我——
What's this? Did you hear what this was?
这是什么？你听到这是什么了吗？
No, I have not.
没有，我没有。
It's probably a regular.
这大概是普通的。
Yeah, that was a regular.
是的，那是普通的。
Over and over, the staff have to gently unwrap the corner of a sandwich to check what it is. Of course, there's a simpler solution to this, a way to label the sandwiches. But--
一遍又一遍，员工不得不轻轻打开三明治的一角检查它是什么。当然，有一个更简单的解决方案，标记三明治的方法。但是——
Marker. Where's the marker? Do you have a marker, Brooke?
记号笔。记号笔在哪？你有记号笔吗，布鲁克？
Jennifer, who's in charge of the trailer, cannot find the one permanent marker that they had. Oh, and also, some of the orders aren't showing up on the overhead computer screens inside the trailer. So everyone's resorted to just yelling out orders at each other.
负责拖车的詹妮弗找不到他们拥有的一支永久记号笔。哦，还有，一些订单没有出现在拖车内部的头顶计算机屏幕上。所以每个人只能诉诸于互相大喊订单。
I need a regular.
我需要一个普通的。
Regular.
普通。
We need a hot mess.
我们需要一个“热乱”。
11-07!
11-07！
Can we get a confirm on that hot mess?
能给我们确认一下那个“热乱”吗？
Yes, you have to wait.
是的，你必须等。
Things feel so out of control that just 45 minutes after the fair's gates have opened, Jamie calls for reinforcements, his 12-year-old daughter and his 19-year-old stepson, Alex.
情况感觉太失控了，就在博览会大门打开45分钟后，杰米呼叫增援，他12岁的女儿和他19岁的继子，亚历克斯。
Hello? Where are you at? OK, you need to get to work. I know you're not supposed to start until 10:00, but we are slammed busy. Just get down here as quick as you can. There's people lined up clear to the street. And your mom probably needs you on the inside.
喂？你在哪儿？OK，你需要开始工作。我知道你不应该在10点开始，但我们忙得不可开交。尽快赶到这儿。人们排队一直排到街上。而且你妈妈可能在里面需要你。
Back out front, I tracked down the customers, Erika and Kris, again. They'd just gotten their food.
回到前面，我再次跟踪了那些顾客，艾丽卡和克里斯。她们刚拿到食物。
It's tasty. It's good, but not worth 35-minute wait.
很好吃。它很好，但不值得等35分钟。
35 minutes?
35分钟？
Yes.
是的。
And what do you think?
那你觉得呢？
It's very good. Yep. I wouldn't wait again.
它非常好。没错。我不会再等了。
The whole thing's kind of painful to watch. People are requesting refunds. It's obvious this is not how this is supposed to go. I was curious how a food stand at the fair is supposed to work, and I didn't have to go far. A couple stands down is an incredibly successful food vendor that's been around for years.
整件事看起来有点痛苦。人们正在要求退款。很明显这不是事情该有的样子。我很好奇博览会上的食品摊位应该如何运作，而且我不必走远。几个摊位之外是一个非常成功的食品摊主，已经经营多年。
Brad and Harry's cheese curds have been at the Iowa State Fair since somewhere in the mid to early '90s.
布拉德和哈利的奶酪凝块（cheese curds）从90年代中期到早期就一直在这里参加爱荷华州博览会。
Matt Rebar runs three cheese curd stands and one poutine stand here at the Iowa fair. And the way they operate has been refined over decades. And the biggest difference I noticed from Jamie and Jennifer's Biscuit Bar? Simplicity, all emanating from this fact.
马特·雷巴在爱荷华博览会上经营三个奶酪凝块摊位和一个肉汁干酪薯条摊位。而他们的运作方式经过了几十年的打磨。我注意到的与杰米和詹妮弗的饼干吧最大的不同？简单，全部源于这个事实。
We have one item. We have one item. It costs one amount. We know they're in line for cheese curds. We know what the change is. We can see in their wallet and know what bill they're going to grab, and we can already have the change ready by the time that transaction happens.
我们只有一种产品。我们只有一种产品。它只花一个金额。我们知道他们在排队买奶酪凝块。我们知道零钱是多少。我们可以看到他们的钱包，知道他们要拿哪张钞票，我们在交易发生时就已经准备好了零钱。
Biscuit Bar, by contrast, has 11 food items and 16 beverage choices, many with a bunch of different customizations.
相比之下，饼干吧有11种食品和16种饮料选择，许多都有各种不同的定制。
It's volume. That's what we're after, is the volume. Quality, but volume.
是量。我们追求的是量。质量，但量。
Inside his trailer, it's tightly packed with employees in a smaller space than Biscuit Bar. But somehow, it's more orderly.
在他的拖车里，员工在比饼干吧更小的空间里挤在一起。但不知何故，它更有条理。
But as far as workstations and positions in here, that's another thing. Everybody in there has one job, and they are within one foot of what they need to do. They don't have to take two steps to do anything in there.
但就这里的工作站和职位而言，那是另一回事。里面每个人都有一项工作，而且他们距离他们需要做的事情只有一英尺远。他们不需要走两步就能做任何事。
Really?
真的吗？
We have enough people where, if you needed to take two steps, we're going to put another person in there to do that for you, just to be efficient as much as possible.
我们有足够的人，如果需要走两步，我们会安排另一个人在那里为你做，尽可能高效。
The trailer was custom-built, so every step of making the food is laid out in perfectly sequential cheese curd assembly stations. Over at the Biscuit Bar, employees make complicated coffee drinks, smoothies, and pour fountain drinks. At Matt's cheese curd stands, his employees don't make drinks at all. Matt sees that as inefficient. Instead--
拖车是定制的，所以制作食物的每一步都布置在完美的序列化奶酪凝块组装站。在饼干吧那边，员工制作复杂的咖啡饮料、冰沙，并倒喷泉饮料。在马特的奶酪凝块摊位，他的员工根本不制作饮料。马特认为那效率低。相反——
We've got a self-serve pop. Pop takes a lot of time, so if we can hand them a cup, they can go take their time, fill their ice as much as they want or as little as they want.
我们有自助式汽水。汽水很花时间，所以如果我们能给他们一个杯子，他们可以去花他们的时间，随心所欲地填满他们的冰块。
One last note about the simplicity of Matt's cheese curd stands-- paper towels. People need them constantly in a kitchen, and Matt has positioned a roll that hangs horizontally from a bungee cord above the workers. They can grab and tear them off effortlessly without taking up any space. Meanwhile, back at Biscuit Bar--
关于马特的奶酪凝块摊位的简单性的最后一个注意点——纸巾。人们在厨房里不断需要它们，马特放置了一个横向悬挂在工人们上方蹦极绳上的卷纸。他们可以毫不费力地抓住并撕下它们，而不占用任何空间。与此同时，回到饼干吧——
This stupid fucking thing.
这个愚蠢的该死的东西。
--Jamie had one of those large, black, mechanized paper towel dispensers that you find in public restrooms, the kind you have to wave your hands under. This morning, it was spitting out only a couple inches of paper towel at a time. The whole first morning, it seemed like Biscuit Bar couldn't catch any luck. Then in the early afternoon--
——杰米有那种你在公共厕所里找到的大型黑色机械纸巾分配器，那种你必须在下面挥手的。今天早上，它一次只喷出几英寸的纸巾。整个第一个早上，饼干吧似乎什么好运都碰不到。然后在下午早些时候——
(SUBJECT) JENNIFER ADKINS: Are you guys ready to order?
（主题）詹妮弗·阿德金斯：你们准备好点餐了吗？
--it finally feels like Biscuit Bar rights the ship.
——饼干吧终于感觉像是在扭转局面。
A piggy? I'll get him a piggy.
一个“小猪”？我给他拿个“小猪”。
Everybody's talking in a more normal volume, the wait times are way shorter, and the kitchen is feeding the sandwich makers what they need when they need it.
每个人都在以更正常的音量交谈，等待时间短得多，厨房也在需要时给三明治制作者提供了他们需要的东西。
There's you some more brisket.
再给你一些布里斯克特肉。
The lines are shorter now, not exactly 10 or 12 people deep, like during the breakfast rush, but there's still a steady flow of customers. People really like Biscuit Bar. I feel hopeful for them. For the first time, I think maybe they could break even. By the time I catch up with Jennifer again, it's closing time, 10:00 PM. She's at the cash register, is printing out the daily totals.
队伍现在更短了，不像早餐高峰期那样有10或12个人排队，但仍然有稳定的顾客流。人们真的很喜欢饼干吧。我为他们感到充满希望。第一次，我觉得也许他们可以收支平衡。当我再次追上詹妮弗时，已经是关门时间，晚上10:00。她在收银机前，正在打印每日总额。
When you print out the totals from the registers, is that the first time you're seeing the numbers?
当你从收银机打印总额时，那是你第一次看到数字吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Jennifer looks over the receipts, then tucks them away. Her face is hard to read, maybe a little solemn.
詹妮弗看着收据，然后把它们收起来。她的脸很难读懂，也许有点庄重。
Can you tell me, looking at the receipts from the first day, do you have a sense of, oh, at this rate, if we do this for 10 days, we could break even or get close to my goal?
你能告诉我，看第一天的收据，你有没有一种感觉，噢，按这个速度，如果我们连续做10天，我们可以收支平衡或接近我的目标？
No. We just have so much money in this stand, and--
不。我们在这一摊位投入了太多的钱，而且——
Really? Even with this big first day, it feels like--
真的吗？即使有这个伟大的第一天，感觉还是——
Yeah.
是的。
Just then, Jamie wanders over.
就在这时，杰米漫步过来。
He was asking if we were-- at this rate, if we would break even. [LAUGHS]
他正在问我们是否——按这个速度，我们是否会收支平衡。[笑声]
No. We got a lot invested in the stand. And my guess, it's two years, three years.
不。我们在这个摊位投入了很多。我的猜测是，两年，三年。
10 days pass. The fair ends, and I check back in with Jamie and Jennifer. They'd both worked from 5:00 in the morning until 11:00 at night on their feet for 11 consecutive days without a break. It was grueling. And the money was way less than they'd hoped for, less than half of what Jamie had predicted. After the food costs and operating expenses, and after the fair took its nearly 20% cut, they were left with about $70,000 profit.
10天过去了。博览会结束了，我与杰米和詹妮弗进行了复查。他们在11天里连续没有休息，从早上5点一直站到晚上11点。这太折磨人了。而钱比他们希望的少得多，不到杰米预测的一半。在食品成本和运营费用之后，在博览会拿走近20%的份额之后，他们留下了大约70,000美元的利润。
$70,000-- good money, but all of it would go towards paying back their original investment, which was, remember, $300,000. At that rate, Jamie and Jennifer will be working for free for four years before they pay off their debts. And after four years, they take home $70,000 every state fair before taxes. A solid chunk of money, for sure. Lots of families would take that deal. But this was still so much less than they talked about earning. Remember, Jamie's estimate would have had them pocketing two or three times that amount.
70,000美元——不错的钱，但全部用于偿还他们的初始投资，记住，那是30万美元。按这个速度，杰米和詹妮弗将在支付债务之前免费工作四年。四年后，他们在税前每个州博览会带回家70,000美元。当然，这是一大笔钱。许多家庭会接受这笔交易。但这仍然比他们谈论赚到的钱少得多。记住，杰米的估计本可以让他们赚到那个金额的两倍或三倍。
So I just wondered, does that math, how does that sit with you? Does that feel worth it to you?
所以我只是想知道，那数学，你感觉如何？你觉得这值得吗？
I think so. I mean, look, I'm not really bothered by it now, after the fact.
我想是的。我的意思是，看，事后看来，我现在真的不为此感到困扰。
I think it's worth it. It's a lot of work, but it's worth it.
我觉得值得。这是一项繁重的工作，但值得。
Jamie told me he was completely unfazed when he saw the numbers come in.
杰米告诉我，当他看到数字出来时，他完全没有被吓到。
You didn't feel anything about, well, I guess we're going to be a little short of kind of half of what I wanted?
你没有感觉到任何东西吗，好吧，我猜我们要离我想要的金额的一半还差一点？
No. No.
不。不。
I think a lot of people would have a hard time adjusting to that reality, or less.
我想许多人很难适应那个现实，或更少。
I wouldn't.
我不会。
Wait, really? I mean, you're a really blunt guy, Jamie. But on this one thing, I got to say, I don't know if I believe you.
等等，真的吗？我的意思是，你是一个非常直率的人，杰米。但在这件事上，我不得不说，我不知道我是否相信你。
Yeah, no, you can believe me. I deal with it all the time. My trucking business, a couple of years ago, done right at $12 million in sales, gross sales. And we won't even be $8 million, probably, this year. I've been in business long enough that I know that just because you made that much money yesterday don't mean you're going to make it today.
是的，不，你可以相信我。我一直都在处理它。我的运输企业，几年前，总销售额做到大约1200万美元。我们今年可能甚至不到800万。我从事生意的时间足够长，我知道仅仅因为你昨天赚了那么多钱并不意味着你今天还会赚到那么多。
I didn't appreciate at first just how much Jamie sees opening a business at the fair as being like a trip to the casino. When he predicted that they'd make $300,000 to $350,000 their first summer, that wasn't because he'd done some careful calculations, counting the number of biscuits you could sell each day.
我起初没意识到杰米把在博览会上做生意看作是去赌场。当他预测他们第一个夏天会赚30万到35万美元时，那并不是因为他做了一些仔细的计算，算出了每天能卖多少饼干。
It was just a wish. He was going to put his money down on the table, roll the dice, and hope for the best. And even though it'll take years before they pay off Biscuit Bar's debts, Jamie is already encouraging Jennifer to open up her coffee shop this upcoming spring. Jennifer isn't so sure if the finances will work. Jamie, though, he feels lucky.
那只是一个愿望。他要在他桌上放钱，掷骰子，并希望获得最好的结果。尽管他们还需要几年时间才能还清饼干吧的债务，杰米已经在鼓励詹妮弗在即将到来的春天开她的咖啡店了。詹妮弗并不确定财务是否会成功。然而，杰米，他觉得自己很幸运。
Chris Benderev, he's one of the producers of today's episode.
克里斯·本德雷夫，他是今天这一集的制作人之一。
Act Four, Last Stand. Saturday night, the part of the park with rides for little kids closes down at 10:00 PM I stopped by there a little before that, wondering if I can talk to Jeremy, the agent of the watergun game.
第四幕，最后摊位。周六晚上，公园里有儿童游乐设施的那部分在晚上10点关闭。我在那之前一会儿顺道过去，想看看能不能和Jeremy，水枪游戏的代理人聊聊。
Come up. Look, I got a family special here for you guys. Closing special, guys. If I get four people to play, whoever wins gets a big choice prize.
上来吧。看，我这儿有个家庭特别优惠。关门特别优惠，伙计们。如果我有四个人玩，谁赢了就选一个大奖。
That hoarse, exhausted-sounding person is Barry, who's doing stock, handling prizes for Jeremy earlier in the day. Now, Jeremy's the one handling prizes, and Barry is on the mic.
那个嗓音嘶哑、听起来筋疲力尽的人是巴里，他早些时候在帮杰里米处理存货，处理奖品。现在，杰里米在处理奖品，巴里在麦克风前。
Right here, are you ready? Have a seat. That's one. I need at least two to start.
就在这儿，你们准备好了吗？坐下。那是一。我至少需要两才能开始。
There are a few straggler families left, and they are keeping themselves as far as they can from Barry, holding a distance of maybe 35, 40 feet. They look beat, and they are not interested in Barry's shenanigans on the mic. Finally, one woman sits down at the game.
还剩下几个掉队家庭，他们让自己离巴里尽可能远，保持着大约35、40英尺的距离。他们看起来被打败了，对巴里在麦克风前的胡闹不感兴趣。最后，一个女人坐下来玩游戏。
I got one in the door. I need at least one more person to start. I see you peeking out there. You can't win it by looking at it, girl. Come on, give it a shot. Show them how it's done.
我这儿有一个。我至少需要一个人才能开始。我看到你在那里探头探脑。看着它你是赢不了的，姑娘。来吧，试一把。给他们展示一下它是怎么做的。
Second woman pulls up in a motorized wheelchair. Barry pleads with people to sit. And when I ask him what this is about--
第二个女人坐着电动轮椅开过来。巴里恳求人们坐下。当我问他这是怎么回事时——
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
We're $100 short from our goal tonight.
我们离今晚的目标还差100美元。
Jeremy tells me that they have a goal to bring in $10,000 that day for the game.
杰里米告诉我，他们那天有一个目标，为游戏赚进10,000美元。
Give it a shot. Look.
试一把。看。
And I want to be clear, this was not management that set this goal. Jeremy did, he said. That's the number he wanted to hit. He and Barry each got a percentage of that $10,000. And they decided on how much they wanted to make for the day. And then they were going to use everything they had to make that number, begging people to sit down.
我想说清楚，这不是管理层设定的目标。杰里米设的，他说。那是他想达到的数字。他和巴里每人拿那10,000美元的百分之几。他们决定了他们想在一天内赚多少钱。然后他们打算用他们所拥有的一切来实现那个数字，乞求人们坐下。
There you go. I got two in the door. I'm looking for two more. What? I need more than two.
这就对了。我这儿有两个。我还要找两个。什么？我需要不止两个。
Barry ends up running a modified two-person version of the game for a smaller prize and keeps going with more rounds.
巴里最终为较小的奖品运行了一个改进的两人版游戏，并继续玩了更多回合。
Who's ready? Who's next?
谁准备好了？下一个是谁？
10:00 comes. The rides around us starts shutting down. Ferris wheel lights go off. That feels weird. This gigantic, multi-colored bright thing, suddenly pitch dark. Very tired clumps of people wander past it towards parking lots. But the water gun race is an island of light and noise.
10点到了。我们周围的游乐设施开始关闭。摩天轮灯关了。那感觉很奇怪。这个巨大的、五颜六色的明亮东西，突然间一片漆黑。非常疲倦的人群徘徊着穿过它朝停车场走去。但水枪竞速赛是一个光明和噪音的岛屿。
Come on. Come on. Last race. Last race of the night. Have a seat, guys. Come on. One more time. We're going to give another big one away, guys. Last race of the night. Last race of the night, guys. Come on up. Give it a shot. One more person.
来吧。来吧。最后一场比赛。今晚最后一场比赛。坐下，伙计们。来吧。再来一次。我们要再送出一个大的，伙计们。今晚最后一场比赛。今晚最后一场比赛，伙计们。过来。试一把。再一个人。
They finally run their last race four minutes after 10:00.
他们在10点过四分最终运行了他们最后一场比赛。
3, 2, 1.
3，2，1。
Four minutes after this part of the park officially closed.
在公园这一部分正式关闭后四分钟。
Don't spill. It's neck and neck. It's toe to toe. Go, go, go, go, go. Who's it going to be? Stop, watch, and see. Number!
别洒了。这旗鼓相当。旗鼓相当。去，去，去，去，去。会是谁？停下，观看，看看。数字！
[BELL RINGING]
[铃声]
Winner, winner, winner. 22, any prize, any size. All right, guys, have a great rest of your night. Thank you all. Appreciate you.
赢家，赢家，赢家。22，任何奖品，任何尺寸。好了，伙计们，祝你们今晚余下时间愉快。谢谢大家。感激你们。
Whatever.
随便吧。
I didn't win.
我没赢。
They're done. Sound system is off. They made their goal, they told me. Jeremy said, when 10:00 hit, of course, they had to keep going.
他们完了。音响系统关了。他们达成了他们的目标，他们告诉我。杰里米说，当10点钟到来时，当然，他们必须继续。
We had a goal. We needed $5 more. All right, we got to flash.
我们有一个目标。我们还需要5美元。好了，我们得去拿货。
Yeah, we got to do stuff.
是的，我们得做点事。
Got to flash means they're not done for the night. They have to head over to where the prizes are stored, get some prizes, come back to the game, and put them in place for tomorrow. He said they started to work around 9:00 that morning. It was 10:00 at night. They had another hour's work to go. We kept going, Jeremy said, because we like money.
“去拿货”意味着他们今晚还没完。他们必须去奖品存放的地方，拿一些奖品，回到游戏那里，为明天做准备。他说他们早上9点就开始工作了。现在是晚上10点。他们还要工作一个小时。我们一直坚持，杰里米说，因为我们喜欢钱。
Our program was produced today by Chris Benderev and Ike Sriskandarajah. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Hany Hawasly, Henry Larson, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由克里斯·本德雷夫和艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾制作。那些参与制作今天节目的人包括Bim Adewunmi，Sean Cole，Michael Comite，Aviva DeKornfeld，Hany Hawasly，Henry Larson，Seth Lind，Miki Meek，Katherine Rae Mondo，Stowe Nelson，Ryan Rumery，Alissa Shipp，Marisa Robertson-Textor，Matt Tierney，和Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Yolanda Stephen, Clinton Wallace, Jodi Weeks, Andy and Scott Schaffer, Jennie Wunderlich, Mindy Williamson, Tyrus Thompson, Kris Olson, Jeff Jones, Sam Stroozas, Melissa and Megan Swartzendruber, Anna Paz Lopez, and Jon Wiederhorn.
我们的常务编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。今天特别感谢Yolanda Stephen，Clinton Wallace，Jodi Weeks，Andy和Scott Schaffer，Jennie Wunderlich，Mindy Williamson，Tyrus Thompson，Kris Olson，Jeff Jones，Sam Stroozas，Melissa和Megan Swartzendruber，Anna Paz Lopez，和Jon Wiederhorn。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以完全免费流媒体收听我们超过800集的档案。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Just this week, he turned down Timothy Chalamet's offer to help him and his wife conceive a child.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的创始人，Torey Malatia先生。就在这周，他拒绝了蒂莫西·柴勒梅德（Timothy Chalamet）帮助他和他的妻子怀孕的提议。
He's cute, but he's not what I'm looking for to bring into my breeding program.
他很可爱，但他不是我想带入繁殖计划的那种兔子。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带着更多《美国生活》的故事。
["I STAYED TOO LONG AT THE FAIR" BY BARBARA STREISAND] Have I stayed too long at the fair?
["我在博览会上呆得太久了" - 芭芭拉·史翠珊] 我是否在博览会上呆得太久了？